pressé par ses partenaires et surtout
par Kiev l'Allemagne a donc donné tout à
l'heure officiellement son feu vert à la
livraison de Charles léopard 2 à
l'Ukraine elle accepte aussi qu'il soit
réexporté à Kiev par des pays
partenaires le chancelier Olaf Scholtz
va s'expliquer tout à l'heure devant le
Bundes stag on rejoint tout de suite à
Berlin notre correspondant à Mayet
bonjour Anne est-ce que vous avez
davantage de détails sur ce qui va être
livré précisément
bien après des mois de débat le
gouvernement allemand confirme par le
biais d'un communiqué que l'Allemagne va
livrer des chair de combat à l'Ukraine
l'objectif étant de fournir de bataillon
de léopard 2 au pays un premier
bataillon constitué de 14 chars de
combat sera envoyé dans un rapide délai
selon le communiqué ces Charentes
proviendront des stocks de la Bundes
verts et puis Berlin confirme vous
l'avez dit également que le gouvernement
donne son feu vert aux autres Européens
volontaires qui souhaitent eux aussi
fournir des chars de combat de type
léopard à l'Ukraine cette décision fait
suite à d'intenses négociations avec les
partenaires européens et internationaux
de l'Allemagne précisent le communiqué
enfin on apprend également que la
formation des soldats Ukrainiens au
maniement de ses chars de combat sera
réalisé en Allemagne et ce dont les plus
brefs délais merci beaucoup Anne pour
ses premières précisions depuis Berlin
et puis